let's go everybody
welcome back and we are live once again
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
we're dealing with me
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
ripping with Griffin thanks for being
here once again
um a lot to talk about today we got
LeBron James getting swept what's next
for the king
there's some crazy AI stories man
artificial intelligence is it getting
off the rails
you know I love American Idol and and
the Husky guy one
did one for the fat guys
so we got that to talk about plus news
and notes and stories
I missed it
yeah
[Music]
I feel like the voice is back thanks for
noticing welcome back to riffing with
Griffin y'all where the woo-woo's come
in strong uh everybody where we got the
woo-woos going woo-woo you know what I
mean so welcome back to River with
Griffin thank you for being here
um you know this is River with Griffin
where we do it you go to
ericgirlfriend.com my terrible website
if you want to uh you know check out
where I am hey as I always say thanks
for being here if this is if you're a
newcomer this is your first time
listening or you're watching live right
now for the first time or you know
you're like oh I heard about your
podcast through something else and I
want to check it out thanks for being
here
you know it's I'm 100 unfiltered I'm
doing it live
um you know sometimes I'm hilarious
sometimes I'm introspective sometimes
I'm serious but I'm always 100 me
so you know those people that are like
[__] this was a comedy podcast sometimes
it is sometimes it's not for the people
that have been here all the time you
know what it's about and I thank you for
always being here and if you want to
continue you got to subscribe so make
sure you subscribe share all that good
stuff uh I'm on Twitch daily come check
me out on Twitch Eric Griffin gaming I'm
always twitching I love that you can
support me there by being a subscriber
or you can even support me on patreon
even though every week I promise new
stuff I haven't done it I'm just busy I
gotta figure out how to do it I think I
want to do like a 20 minute yeah I I'm
I'm thinking about how I want to do it
but anyways
and also um like where where'd it go
where's the patreon sign it didn't show
up oh this thing would be messing up man
but anyway oh there it is but anyways
um also
I will be if you want to see me live
stand up um I'm coming to Nashville's in
zany's Nashville's Wednesday when is
that Wednesday in June I think it's the
one of the last Wednesdays in June so
make sure you come check me out in
Nashville because it's just gonna be one
night uh in June in
um Nashville you got the 21st so June
21st I'm gonna be in Nashville
and then for the weekend Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm going to be in Huntsville
so if you're in the Nashville Huntsville
area get your tickets now man let's show
them that you know let's show zany's in
Nashville that I should have been there
for the whole weekend so all my
Nashville peeps come check me out maybe
uh let's sell this out and maybe they
have to add a second show on Wednesday
who knows let's figure it out uh so
spread the word please if you're in that
area come check me out so anyways
welcome back to River with Griffin
thanks everybody that's live in chat on
YouTube right now
appreciate you guys you could uh you
know
put uh what do you call it um
super chats and all that stuff if you
want to help with that kind of stuff too
I really appreciate that too so anyways
and then all and everybody listening on
Apple and all that at least some leave
some comments and some reviews there too
please because that really helps push
the algorithm to to get uh riffen with
Griffin out there so welcome back uh
let's see any news and notes in the
family this week you know there's always
something going on with Rachel and me
nothing this week actually we actually
had a uneventful week
everything was cool we like uh
you know it's nothing yeah it's like um
yeah there was nothing yeah she's the
best love her shout out to her so thank
you rage for being you
um let's just go right into some
comments from last week because I do
have some thoughts about last week's
episode and there was a lot of comments
which was great
um let's see here
um oh in terms of uh so this guy I can't
you guys with your dumb names dude your
dumb stupid usernames okay whatever this
guy is kanoi 55 James Gunn is the new
head of DC I didn't know that I just
wasn't paying attention but you know
James gunny directed Guardians of the
Galaxy three oh I think he wrote and
directed all three of them he gave a
good send off I thought it was a great
movie I really enjoyed it you could see
the review from last week's episode and
so now apparently he's taking over the
DC and you know what I'm glad to hear
that because I think he's a great
director and I think he's got a good
handle on storytelling to uh combine
look the MCU
to me Marvel Universe they're in trouble
they're in trouble after
um you know end game
this kind of disjointed story that
they're telling with these horrible
movies that they're making
I I there and how they're not really
connected is a problem for me if you
enjoyed what they did before look you
had from Iron Man to Captain America to
Thor to all these movies they made
even if it was a terrible movie you knew
it's serviced what was coming
so we dealt with a couple of the bad
ones you know we dealt with a cup like
we dealt with Iron Man Three
you know what I mean we dealt with Thor
dark World horrible you know we dealt
with some but these movies that they've
been coming out with are so like doesn't
feel connected they were kind of like
well what story are you telling if
you're a true fan you're like a deep fan
and you're like I I know what's
happening but I just I think they did a
better job before and lastly I'll say
about it is we're not given enough
respect to what Robert Downey Jr did to
keep that together
like he's the glue man he would he to me
him not being in the MCU is terrible
it's like they they haven't found
somebody
Cumberbatch is like the closest
Force
Doctor Strange you know he's the closest
force that sort of has that vibe but
those movies are just kind of like
I don't know tell me what you think do
you think MCU is doing a good job or you
know is it time now for DC Universe to
like get their [__] together and uh see
what's going on there so I don't know
man
um yeah oh yeah and shout out to Tony
hinchcliffing the kill Tony crew if
anybody's here from Kill Tony uh I love
that show I loved it's such a unique
experience uh so shout out to Tony and
red band and the mothership uh and
everybody that was a you know William
Montgomery guys you got to check out
William Montgomery he is
I did this podcast with William
Montgomery and David Lucas way back in
the day and million William Montgomery
was a mess he was like drunk and it was
like I was so mad at them and since then
he has gotten his life together and he
is just one of the funniest human beings
out there so make sure you go you know
if you have a chance to see William
Montgomery live or if you're in the
Austin area or just check out his
calendar man the dude's hilarious same
thing with David Lucas too David Lucas
is out there doing his thing and uh
shout out to Joe Rogan for giving a
space for those young Comics to like to
shine so shout out to all the kill Tony
people if you're here from uh kill Tony
fun stuff man uh anyway let's keep going
with the comments
um let's see what we got here oh
somebody's asking for a John Wick 4
review uh you know what I might throw
that in this week uh well you know what
you asked for it
you know it is what it is man John Wick
it's one of those like it's turned into
a guilty pleasure if you want to if you
like watching Keanu Reeves do slow Kung
Fu and and some crazy gun Play It's the
movie for you man and you know it didn't
disappoint in terms of that you know uh
it's just you know it's still it's still
like how
how did how can the high table lose 500
people and still continue that's the
only thing I have with it you know I
mean the story is just like whatever
it's the same sort of thing John Wick's
on the Run trying to like you know
I don't know what he's doing in this one
and I don't know what his motivation was
in John Wick 4 if I'm being honest but
it was great sword play and gun play and
fighting the only knock I have on J like
I can't believe he could kill all these
people
what I can't believe
is he can fall from a two-story building
fall two stories onto a hood of a car
and still be able to fight I'm out on
that everything else I can suspend my
disbelief but I can't suspend my
disbelief of how many times this guy
falls from roofs and survives
no thank you I'm sorry it just
I can't I can't so but it was it was
still great and I hope they keep making
them because there's something special
about Keanu Reeves I just I love that
guy okay so there's your quick John Wick
4 review and that was Jake white 4522 so
or Jackie white four five two two thank
you
uh uh okay let's see here
um what we got here
look here's somebody
monster0033 about that tipping story
uh there's companies in Colorado now
that has approved stores like Walmart
and McDonald's that have made it
possible for the employees to receive
tips for that I say pay your damn
employees out of the billions you make
each year in profit take them you know I
totally agree he says more but like
monster003 I totally agree it's like so
we have to pay for the food and
supplement the income that you don't
want to pay companies how much money do
you need to make you know what I mean
I'm not I'm not trying to be a socialist
but it's just like God damn we gotta pay
you know it's like pay them you know
what I mean
uh let's see Tony
guzman6798 says Montez can we get a what
segment every episode 70k for a damn
mattress I mean yeah I know I say it a
lot anytime something crazy goes I go
what so maybe we will call it that
segment so we'll see
[Laughter]
uh Stephen back 1656 1665 said I'm here
for Al Goron Rhythm or Rhymes or
whatever he's trying to say
old man rap recap
um
ashton3049 said he's right about the
Jordan LeBron debate I don't even know
what it how what reference you're saying
for that
uh let's see
um let's see uh let's see let me go let
me keep going
somebody said Mark
vasquez2209 said I was guessing 20 000
for the mattress but seventy thousand I
mean for real right we actually ended up
getting a mattress by the way just
mattress update uh and it was very
expensive I'm just I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna lie you know what I mean Daddy's
doing all right you know and Rachel just
here's the thing here's my Rachel's
story for this week and this is just
this is a marriage thing
if I'm gonna make a big purchase for the
house
I have to make sure she likes it
even if let's say there's two options
there's option A and option b and
there's part of me that's like I really
want option A
and I've looked into it I'm like option
A is probably the better option but
option b is probably it's it's as good
and there's different things and I may
not like it but if she doesn't like it
we could she don't like hey we gotta go
with B if she's like why really like me
and I'll tell you why because
she gonna make my life miserable if I
would have got a even if it's better and
just one time she lays on the mattress
and it's like ah you know this one is
not as good then I'm my life is my life
is miserable
so I gotta get the one she likes because
then if she don't like it you understand
what I'm saying if there's any moment
she was like I could be like well this
is the one you wanted babe and then it's
done then we just living with it you
know what I mean
I know it's okay but hey married people
get it if you married out there dudes
married dudes out there know exactly
what I'm talking about so it is what it
is all right let me do a couple more
comments uh and if you want to comment
get your comments sent and maybe you
even want to send me an email at
ericgriffin.com send me an email if you
want to like you know hey just put
comment in the uh just you know this is
whatever you put something put comment
in the subject line comment for riffen
with Griffin you know what I mean uh
let's see uh I don't know here
uh oh well that that's it that that's
enough for the comments you know what I
mean that's enough comments for now
uh and yeah I do see the comments while
talking for the people that are in chat
right now I see you guys
um I'm not really trying to you know I
guess I guess they have this little
section here I could do
um you know
there's like there's like a q a section
I should put that here
so then if you if you have a question
for me right now you could put it in
that q a section you know and then I'll
be able to I'll be able to get to that
right there you know what I mean so if
anybody's got something there you could
do it there too so anyways thanks for
being here all right guys uh let's get
into some stuff
um as you know the NBA man
dude
um so all right so if we go back last
week if we go back to like you know I
made some predictions and stuff like
that and um
I've always said Denver Denver's the
best team all right they had a better
team they're just well coached they got
jokic they're just ready they're
tailor-made the Lakers overachieved you
know they really did the Lakers
overachieved they got to the Western
Finals which was like a miracle
starting 2 and 13 of the Season or two
and ten whatever it not working with
what Russell Westbrook was which which
was like just an ultimate failure from
the beginning I think the Lakers I think
the Lakers and this is LeBron James's
fault in my opinion I think the Lakers
should have stuck to their guns and and
put the best team they could have
possibly put around him with the players
that they had man you think about all
the players that are out there that the
Lakers had like uh Caruso Kyle kuzma
Caldwell Pope they had so many of these
uh even James Randall you know even
James his name James Randall Randall
with the Knicks like all these guys were
Lakers he they had all these guys you
know what I mean
whatever the trades they made to get A.D
they still let guys go that they didn't
have to let go to get Russell Westbrook
for instance that just that wasn't gonna
work so I just feel like they wasted his
last years man they got one Championship
out of it and this was a great chance to
do it but they ran into a buzz saw man
um but shout out to the Denver Nuggets
and all you Denver Nuggets fans you know
they finally doing it this is it yokich
is showing like why he is a two-time MVP
and he probably should have been MVP
this year uh so you know I think the
Denver Nuggets are in a good spot right
now and and then you know
so in terms of Lakers and LeBron James
what's he gonna do you know it's like
LeBron like he had this cryptic final uh
this cryptic press conference but listen
when you're in the Heat of the Moment
you just lost and you lost because you
didn't show up like like LeBron James
had 40 points in this game 30 points in
the first half and he it the balls in
his hands to tie the game and he
couldn't do what he's done his whole
career that's got to be hard for the guy
that's got to be hard for to be like you
did your very best at 38 years old you
came out here and tried to be arguably
the best player on the court in that
game and it wasn't enough
did his teammates not show up yes I mean
I feel like Anthony Davis is like yo bro
you're supposed to be the best player
now how you gonna let a 38 year old a
dude eight years older than you like
outshine you every single night it's
like come on man you got to take it upon
yourself too to be like I got this and
like you know give us a 39 point game in
the in the final and in your closeout
game you know what I mean you're already
down 3-0 so you know I don't know and so
I think he's sitting here contemplating
like what am I gonna do but here's the
thing too there's a hundred million
dollars on the table for him to play two
more seasons how do you not do that I
mean the dudes all the dude's
practically are billionaire so I don't
know if it's necessarily about the money
maybe but it's like man
uh this it's crazy man crazy okay
so you know what do we what what are you
supposed to do so I know he also wants
to play with his son but there's a lot
of factors that go with that who knows
if brawny's even good enough but I guess
if you're an NBA team and you're like
look LeBron James will come to your team
for his final year uh or final and
because he wants to play with his son
and then that's like box office right
like who doesn't want to see that like a
39 40 year old LeBron James on the
basketball court with his son in the NBA
that'll be like wow but the novelty of
that'll go till like mid-season and then
we'll be like dude get this old dude off
of here in this sorry ass kid if he's
not good you know what I mean like so
but if if they are good like imagine
what that'll look like you know so
that's good and shout out to Joe Dyer
you happy in chat people are like show
mute
you know that's um
we'll see what's going on with that so I
think this does tarnish LeBron James
Legacy a little bit you know I I think
Jordan he just pushed Jordan ahead again
you know he just pushed Jordan to the
top of the you know he was like running
and then he's getting towards him then
he just went ah he pushed him forward
you know but LeBron James solid number
two and you could still make an argument
that he's the greatest player of all
time but I think that this is uh you
know but you know listen they could get
a good player next year like if they get
like they could get like Trey young or
they could get Kyrie Irving I think
Kyrie Irving can just walk away from
Dallas I think he's an unrestricted free
agent he could just be like buy it Alice
and just go to the Lakers and they have
30 million dollars under the cap they
would just have to convince Kyrie Irving
to take less money than but I don't
think any team is going to pay Kyrie
Irving 40 million dollars a year anyway
so he should just take whatever he can
get for his final you know final major
contract and just like you know try to
get a championship at this point you
know I think if the Lakers had Kyrie
Irving right now I think they would have
beat Dallas I mean um Denver if they had
Kyrie Irving they would have beat Denver
um because like you need he's that go-to
guy you know then LeBron doesn't have to
he can just do that thing that he's been
doing being like the glue so we'll see
it's gonna be very interesting next year
to see if he comes back he for sure has
to get foot surgery which is crazy that
he was playing the way he's been playing
um but ankles are pretty like crazy man
he may never recover from that to him
he's also 38 your body doesn't bounce
back the same as it did so we'll see but
shout out to the Lakers and LeBron James
and shout out to Denver all you die hard
Denver fans Denver did it they were the
best team all year in the Western
Conference and probably the league and
they proved it and now they're going
into the thing I think they're going to
win the championship okay
now let's go to the Eastern Conference
okay now in the East okay all you Miami
Heat fans looks listen I picked the
Sixers to beat the Celtics okay and the
Sixers choked like man you know what
we're missing now we're missing
Joel embiid versus jokic that's what we
wanted that would have been a great
story and the Sixers choked it away they
fired Doc Rivers which Justified like
I'm sorry
I was a Clippers fan I think the
Clippers could have won a championship
during those uh Lob City years man or at
least gotten to the championship and I
just think Doc Rivers is to me he's one
of the most overrated coaches of all
time okay he was a good he was gonna be
fired in Boston and then they traded for
Kevin Garnett to play with Paul Pierce
and they got Ray Allen to have a big
three and even in Nat's big three season
they went game seven every single game
they didn't dominate at all and they
never won a championship again and I
think that's because of Doc Rivers doc
Rivers's record in game sevens terrible
elimination games terrible
um UPS up 3-2 and losing it's terrible
like terrible terrible terrible get out
okay and I think that they ruined that
chance all right they they had such a
great chance now let's get to the
Celtics all you Celtics fans I've been
saying for a long time now that I don't
think Joe Missoula is ready to be a head
coach I think he's showing his
inexperience I think his inexperience is
the reason why they're in the position
they're in now they barely won that
Series against the Sixers but and
because you know like I say man better
coaching better play from James Harden
and and the MVP of the league they win
that easily but anyways it didn't happen
that way so the Celtics moved on but his
inexperience versus Eric's bolster right
now Miami is glaring
and now they're down 3-0 to Miami who
who's on Miami man they got six or seven
undrafted players and Jimmy Butler who
arguably Jimmy Butler like we have to
start looking at Jimmy Butler being like
well he might be one of the greatest
players ever he might need to Vault
himself up into the top 15 players of
all time but it's just because he's been
at so many different locations so many
different places that it's it's hard to
listen it's hard to look at his career
and totality and be like well what did
he really do so it'll be one of those
things you look back in retrospect but
he is clearly a Hall of Famer
um
it's incredible they're up 3-0
that being said
hear me now hey I love talking Sports
and I'm not necessarily in the
prediction business but let me tell you
this
if any team has a chance to come back
from a 3-0 deficit it is this year's
Boston Celtics and I'll tell you why
it's the whole scenario so Boston goes
Boston there of the home team game one
and two they lose both home games
they lose their first game in Boston all
right so now they win the fourth game in
Miami it's now 3-1 now the next two out
of three games are in Boston
that's interesting
they already won the game obviously they
have to win every single game now
what they have to do they have to win
this home game in Boston they absolutely
have to win and they gotta win it
convincingly they have to show up with
some pride and effort and they have to
win that game now if they win game five
in Boston
I think the momentum's in their favor I
think everybody's going to be talking
about it and I think that they're going
to have hope I think they're going to be
like you know what we could actually do
this all we got to do is get to game
seven
we gotta get to game seven because it
will be on their home floor
and then
I'm telling you this is actually the
perfect scenario to come back from three
at down 3-0
it's the perfect scenario they've been
pretty terrible at home I get you they
just lost right but what I'm saying is
this is the kind of scenario you could
come back from 3-0 that's all I'm saying
come on man Boston is the better team
they have better players they're just
not playing well they're not shooting
well they're not they're not showing up
they have nothing to lose now it's like
look we're down 3-0 everybody's already
counted us out that's a great mentality
mental space to be in all I'm saying is
can they get to game seven
because if they get to game seven we're
all gonna be like it's gonna be like a
great Sports story it's gonna be a great
watch it's just you know what I'm saying
like
I want that to happen I want the Boston
Celtics to get to a game seven that will
be tremendous it will be incredible man
it'll it'll be the sports story of the
year and then you're talking the two
best teams in the league going at each
other in the championship so let's hope
for that because in my opinion and I
know how can you doubt Miami how can we
keep doubting Miami I know you Miami
fans you love Miami and you're always
good you're sending me messages man you
got stopped out in Miami man we're here
Miami's here okay I totally agree with
you but damn I don't see Miami having a
chance against the Denver Nuggets
they're just too good man right
and so I don't think it's even gonna be
a series I think Denver I think Denver
is going to put the whoop on Miami like
I think it's gonna they're finally gonna
reach a team that is equally as coached
well has great play they've been battle
tested they are ready okay they're ready
to win this Championship I think
Boston's the only team that has a chance
against Denver but again if Miami makes
the championship what a story that would
be too though right Miami beating dead I
mean wow
that'd be incredible I don't see it
happening
I know I'm sorry I'm doubting Miami
again sorry Jimmy Butler I mean what
Jimmy's done is just incredible but
we'll see what's going on with that but
as of right now I just don't I don't
know so tell me what you think if you're
a Miami fan if you're a basketball fan
uh uh you know we'll see what's going on
but again I'm not saying the suctions
are going to come back from 3-0 but I am
saying this is a perfect scenario for
them to come back from 3-0 okay this is
like it's it's perfectly set up
two out of the three games remaining are
in Boston
you know come on now you can do it
um
yeah amazing right
[Laughter]
so we'll see man it's just
anyways all right so there's that story
right there loved it
um
all right guys I want to go to some of
these crazy uh
Instagram stories that's going on right
now well I mean just not crazy but it's
just I just love going from stories that
I you know on Instagram so here's one of
them right here is that uh so I had
talked about this before but Netflix is
now charging an additional fee for
password charity United States it's now
here it's here y'all they've been
talking about it they tested it out in
like Latin America and other places to
see what was going on and according to
reports
they did have some cancellations people
were like I'm canceling but then they
saw that shortly after people were
people resubscribed they were like I
need my Netflix you know what I mean so
I don't know what do you guys think what
are you gonna do uh you know like I
don't know how it's gonna affect me yet
like I don't password share but it's
like in the household so it's like you
know I have Netflix here in the house
right but like when I go on the road and
I'm traveling I I use my Netflix on my
iPad and stuff like that so I hope that
like they better not do that where it's
like well oh if you're traveling you
can't use your Netflix like what that's
that'd be crazy or like just because I'm
on the road can somebody in my house
still watch you know Netflix you know
what I mean like I I don't know how
they're gonna do that but let's see
so if you're like a Netflix fan what
like what are you guys gonna do again I
love to hear comments and stuff about
that what do you think oh and apparently
they're gonna charge
7.99 for
um they're gonna charge 7.99 for the uh
for the like if you if you're sharing it
with someone or are they just gonna
charge you if they start to see like hey
you've been uh you've been
using your Netflix in two or three
different locations at once so here's a
7.99 charge for that so that's you know
you know I know we're like how much
money do you need to make but it's like
look when a company
gives you a service and it's a great
service that you enjoy using for a
minute that's not a lot of money uh 19 a
month or eight dollars whatever the the
tier you're using that's a great you
know a great price for all the
entertainment that you're getting for
that and it just so happens it's made by
one company and then they make a lot of
money because they have a lot of people
that like the service I don't know if we
should always like blame a company like
because they provide a great service
we're supposed to be mad at them because
they make money you know I mean I get it
it's like how much money do you need to
make so it's like if at 19 a month
everybody's paying 19 a month and
they're making 34 billion dollars a year
we go uh maybe you can make 15 billion
instead of 30. you know what I'm saying
it's still a lot of money so I don't
know like it just depends on what yeah I
don't know capitalism is what it is man
so
I don't know you tell you you got to
tell me what you guys think of that let
me go to my q a area and see if anybody
had anything to say no there's none
there nobody said anything there all
right
um all right speaking of money and
making money here's another social media
post I like from uh what What's the name
of this call this website it's called
puberty I think I love their what their
their Instagram page uh I love that but
this is again speaking of money and
making money a new study finds that more
money can buy happiness
I thought that was so funny so
they're saying money can buy happiness
so before it was some sort of uh they
had a they had a threshold so it was
like
let's say 10 years ago or something it
was like if you're at like 70 80 000 a
year you there was like some happiness
connected to that because I guess I
don't know if it's necessary about the
happiness so much as it's about the
negative things that are added to your
life because you don't have any money or
taken away like when you're struggling
to pay your bills that is something that
causes distress uh you know if you're
struggling to pay like you know you want
to send your kid to a better school and
you can't afford it or you don't have
the right health care because you don't
have enough money like all the things
that you can't get because you don't
have money so the things you do have
that are not as good may cause you some
distress so when you take those things
away you're like oh I'm not worrying
about that stuff is that what happiness
is so but now the new study is it's like
now the number 10 years later is like
500 000. like you got to be making 500
000 a year and that's like where the
happiness threshold starts
uh
uh you know what I mean so the
so it's like a weird number so so what
do you so what do you guys think do you
think money can buy happiness
you know there's that old stain you know
money can't buy happiness you know it's
like but it's like uh I think I'd rather
try I think we all would be like well
I'd rather have the money and like see
how my happiness level is as opposed to
being like but I don't think people me
like when they say money buys if you're
a person that says money can't buy
happiness
you you're that doesn't mean you're
saying being poor you can be happy I
don't think that's what you mean that's
like that's not the that's the extreme
you know we don't want to go to the
extremes of it I think there's some
Nuance in there right there's some
Nuance in there and you know we could
discuss it you know I see someone in
chat said Netflix file for bankruptcy
several times how are they still making
content
that's because you don't understand what
bankruptcy means like when people file
for bankruptcy when they're uh uh you
know when they are like when you like
there's there's ways that people that
make a lot of money file for bankruptcy
to not have to pay their bills off or
whatever it is I mean it works out man
and I think that was a long time ago
when they did that and then and when
they were trying to do it okay but look
look at all reports man they have over
200 million subscribers okay it you know
even at 200 million subscribers a month
even if they were only paying ten
dollars a month that's I believe if my
math is correct
two billion dollars a month
is my math right you just add another
zero to the bill to the 200 million
right you know
that's two billion dollars a month right
that's just at ten dollars I'm saying
there's no way they don't have money
okay but anyway right Alfred Wayne I
totally agree it doesn't make it worse
can can can money buy happiness yeah but
I don't it doesn't make it worse I think
again the Nuance of it is what kind of
person are you
I mean the real issue is when you get a
lot of money is like what are you going
to do to change your lifestyle I mean
that's the thing I'm sure there's a
number of people here making between you
know 30 000 to 70 000 a year okay I mean
that's like if you're you know and
that's that's pretty successful to to
most people you know what I mean so if
you're in that range and let's say you
you know what are you gonna do with your
life if you got more money if You Were
Somehow given 250
000 a year job all right but you're
living right now at forty fifty thousand
dollars a year
if you don't change your lifestyle
that 250 000 that you're gonna get now
you're gonna live pretty great you're
not gonna have worries and issues as as
you as you might think right
but what happens to people is this
they change their lifestyle
if your rent right now is
12.50 a month and you have two roommates
and you live in a nice place let's say
you live in a nice maybe you live in a
town home or something
you got some roommates but you like your
lifestyle you know you got a nice car
you got a car that you like you know
maybe you want a better car
you know maybe your car note is like 350
a month you got your 1250 uh a run rent
that you're splitting you're splitting
utilities with people y'all splitting
the internet you know you're going out
on the weekends
maybe you got a gym membership at the
gym that you like there's something that
you're like there's something that
you're spending money on that you go
okay that's my guilty pleasure money but
you all right
once I give you 250
000 a year now you're gonna be like I'm
rich now you moving out of your house
you moving out of that 1250 a month
place you moving out you got guy bye
guys I'm getting my own apartment now
I'm just talking about you living in LA
right so now you should you like I'm
about I'm gonna I want my own one
bedroom and I'm moving into a better
neighborhood I don't know if you've been
looking at rents but now you talking
like three thousand to four thousand
dollars a month just you now you paying
that you paying all your utilities
yourself you know you're gonna have
Netflix Hulu you're gonna get all that
now you're getting the Equinox
membership so you went from
3 500 a month in expenses oh by the way
you also getting a better car because
she's like I got to get a better car
your car note's now 750 your insurance
is now higher so you went from spending
3 500 a month and all your expenses to
seven eight nine thousand dollars a
month not even thinking about it because
you're making you think you're making
this extra money so let's say your
expenses get up to ten thousand dollars
a month because you make it 250. okay
guys that's now a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in expenses for the
year
tax on 250 is about 40 percent state tax
uh
you know so that 250 is really now only
one something
and you you've now raised your expenses
now all the same issues and worries that
you had before
are still there
because you've now raised your level the
thing is don't raise your level maybe or
don't raise it as much
and then you really won't have the worry
of not having money
that's where I'm at y'all I've made some
money I've done some TV shows things
happen sometimes I'll have a big payday
on a on a on a weekend at a club where I
sold out the shows sometimes a a cartoon
will come up or or some something with
gaming you know I made some good money
gaming during the pandemic and like
every now and then an event will come up
and I'll make like you'll be like wow
you got that to play video games and so
that stuff I put it away you know and uh
you know uh the little residuals I get
from all the things I've done throughout
my years I put it away and then so I can
be comfortable
but I'm because I'm older so I'm like
I'm thinking about like am I gonna do
this forever there's no retirement plan
for my business so I have I live a
modest life
you know and then I have this you know
my young wife who like she likes fancy
stuff so now I I do my my expenses in a
way where I'm like well my wife wants
this so I'm gonna get her that so she
can be happy and I'm cool with it
because I got the money because I'm not
doing something crazy you know what I
mean I'm not making my expenses crazy so
when I want to go let's go to Europe
let's go to Europe for two weeks and
spend such and such amount of money and
fly first class I got that because I
have made sure that I've put money away
that I'm living a certain lifestyle
that's what to me you have to do that's
what happiness becomes is being able to
do the things that you want to do
because you're not a slave to a high
expenses that you because you want to
live a certain way you know what I mean
I'm not buying the 70 000 bed no
that's what I'm saying that's not the
kind of nonsense I do I go no no we're
not getting that you know what I mean
we're not getting there but I did buy a
Tempur-Pedic and you look it up
Tempur-Pedic ain't cheap you know what I
mean and we got the good one so
you know anyways
there's that
[Laughter]
um all right so now
um one of the stories I want to get into
now is like you guys know I love me some
American Idol
I love American Idol
so
American Idol you know I've been talking
about American Idol
I am shocked I'm shocked and proud of
the American of the voters that the
American Idol fans
one and you know if you've been watching
my podcast I've been saying for weeks
now
that once I saw these final three I was
like there's no way
there's no way that the fat guy is gonna
win because that's just not what America
does it was Colin style this chick right
here what's her name
um she's great I'm just telling you
right now this chick is great uh but I
forgot her name I can't stand when I
don't get people's names like but anyway
this country girl she's great okay I
would be fine with any one of these
three winning winning right but I didn't
think he would win because this is just
not what people do that's not what
America does the people that watch
americanologists Middle America people
for the for years now they've been
voting for for the most part
you know if there's a a good looking
white guy with a guitar he has the
advantage in the finals that's just how
it's been y'all that's how it's been
what do you want me to say all right it
is what it is okay
so
I was surprised this is usually how it
goes Colin style is his name but he's
great I'm just saying there's been times
in the past where I'll be like that
guy's not better than whoever the ethnic
or or female singer that they were up
against that guy's not better last year
I thought the the the dude the big black
guy he was the best singer he didn't
even make the finals so I was surprised
that of the first three they kicked
Colin style out I was like Wow and then
it was between these two and I was like
oh I think the girl's gonna win just
because of the history of American Idol
right but let's say this
this kid Ian tongi I am I am he his
audition went viral because it was so
emotional his father died he's playing
his father's guitar he's singing that
James Blunt song and we just it went
viral it got over a hundred million
views because people were like oh that's
a great story we love a great story and
the kid can sing he's a great singer so
then cut to the finals
he's
singing the same song with James Blunt
and it's this emotional song and he's
crying I'm telling you I'm crying
Rachel's crying I'm texting with people
to watch American Idol they're crying
and then at that moment I was like he's
gonna win
okay
he I was like he's winning because of
this right here and it was like and
that's the beauty of television and the
magic of television and you know what
I'm saying and it's like is he the best
singer of the three
no I think the girl is she's the best
singer but he got all this now here's
the next question though all right we
picked him it's a competition show he
won what's gonna happen next is he gonna
go on to be an international Superstar I
don't know
you know I just don't know now that when
the magic Haze wears off and now it's
time to go buy a em tungie record are
these Middle America people gonna do
that no they're not I'm sorry
this girl she's gonna be a country star
and you're going to know her name in
five years and you're not gonna remember
this guy that's just my thing but who
knows if I'm still doing referral
Griffin in five years and he's an
international star and he's won a couple
of Grammys I'll be I'll be like well I
was wrong but that's what I think is
going to happen I think the country boy
he's gonna come out with an album too
he's gonna be a star man he's gonna be
like you know so I don't know now here's
the thing
this is the reason why I'm bringing this
up there's like American Idol winner I'm
taking speaks out for the first time
after rigged backlash so there's like a
people who are saying it's rigged
American Idol fans claim competition
rigged as em tuggies the winner
now here's my issue with this
and I talk about this a lot on Golden
hour I talk about it I'm talking about
it I talk about it here
this is why you need to have Artistic
integrity be the thing we care about
most in our society
Artistic integrity has to be the most
important thing
before diversity before inclusion
because if you don't make that the thing
and you don't establish a reputation
like American Idol is supposed to be
you're establishing that we think this
is the best singer the best Idol
when you have all this social politics
involved in things this is what you get
this is the results you get
people of what the result of how people
are talking about it
now because we're our society is so much
about
you know
social politics now when a kid who
genuinely sings well who had a great
story who moved us emotionally when he
wins you got people going ah well that's
not right
uh we feel like it's rigged and that's
because of you [__] out here pushing
your agenda on society as opposed to it
being about
who's the best man
they don't do this in sports that's why
Sports is perfect it's a meritocracy so
Sports
is how we should it should be
we don't care about
the the sob story
the dude that's got the sob story in the
NBA and he's like you know my father
trained me and my father died and you
know please NBA team pick me up now
we're like can you shoot can you dribble
you know what I'm saying can you put the
ball in the basket are you athletic
because that's all we care about in
sports I don't care about your story I
don't care about your story and it's are
you the best person for this situation
that's what we got to get back to so
people can't be coming at us being like
yo
we need to there needs to be more
diversity nah man
and by the way that also goes to the the
white majority out there only picking
white people like you're part of the
problem too we need you to have Artistic
integrity as well
for for for so long in our society
the people in charge didn't care about
Artistic integrity they just cared about
their agenda and it just so happens that
the people in charge were mostly White
okay
it doesn't necessarily mean it's racist
you know it's Tribal a lot in a lot of
cases right you want to pick people that
look like you I get it the majority of
people are white it ain't always a
racial discussion but what I'm saying is
it goes both ways
we just got to get to a point where
something like American Idol when a dude
like this wins we go well he was the
best you know he had the best story he
had a great voice and I lied I liked him
and I picked him
the reason why this is happening is
because of
the other side pushing an agenda so much
remember when it was Oscars to White and
it was like hashtag options too well the
Oscars are white the Oscars are white so
next year
which movie wins the gay black movie
the gay black movie wins and then
everyone was like wow the gay black
movie The only reason why the gay black
movie won is because of the Oscar so it
took away from it you're not Servicing
you're not servicing the people that you
think
with how what how you're doing this when
you're doing that when you push an
agenda you're not servicing the people
you think you're helping because all it
does is take away the Integrity of the
thing it takes away the integrity
uh what was that movie uh uh uh what was
it that movie I'm talking about
um the oh man I don't even remember the
damn movie I won over uh um
whatever that movie was it probably was
the best movie of the year but now we
can't even look at it like that because
of the movement
it's just being done the wrong way it's
being executed the wrong way and I don't
like it
I don't like it man and as a person of
color I don't like it I want to be
picked because I'm the best when I go
for an audition I don't want to be
picked because and this is what happens
in my situation you know how many times
I've gone on auditions where clearly
this was written for a White Guy they've
gone through the whole process and then
they go oh no I think we got to get we
got to change the best friends got to be
a person of color next thing you know
I'm I'm brought in and I'm reading a you
know I'm reading lines for Barry or I'm
reading lines for somebody named John
and he's clearly in the script you go
well I don't know if this guy is a
person of color and it's like just you
know what I mean it's like it's like
pushing an agenda does not service me
because now why am I in here am I in
here because I'm good because I'm the
best or am I just in here because you
try to fill a quota it takes away from
the Integrity man and I'm tired of it
and so now this kid who is great
right now we gotta look oh it's rigged
because what
if he was a big fat white guy doing the
same thing would we be saying it's
rigged I guarantee you we wouldn't if he
was a big fat white guy from Hawaii and
he he had the whole same story oh they
would have he would be the winner and
everybody would be like oh wow what a
great yay Ian his name would be M it
would be in
you know what I mean his name would be
Ian and and we would say anything I
don't like that
okay I don't
okay we're almost there
and I hear Rachel's home
Rachel
I'm doing my podcast live you know I've
never done this before live but come say
hello
you guys listening if you're listening
later you're probably like what is going
on but uh all right last up I do have
one last uh story about
uh you know before we end oh wow wow we
really been zooming moving and grooving
right here so here's one of the stories
I also wanted to talk about is this uh
hey hi man AI is going crazy dude like
that there's so many of these type of
stories in AI a man was scammed by a
deep fake video and audio imitating his
friend a man in China lost 4.3 mil hold
on hold on babe hold on I'm in the
middle of a story here
I know you like to interrupt me after
Rachel Griffin everybody a man in China
okay you know what let me just she's you
know what I mean just this is my own
fault I did this to myself
come say hi everybody this is my
beautiful wife Rachel hi Rich hi
hi okay get out of here
[Applause]
it's a weird moment in podcasting
history right there babe what are you
doing babe I'm
check under your chair what is it
okay
huh you're on it you're gonna rip it oh
I've already deposited that
leave to her to see money underneath my
chair
oh man all right anyways
I hope I did deposit this one I never
know anyways so anyways so AI guys AI is
really something's going on here
you know what I mean look at this look
at this nerd look at this there's so
many needy people in the chat that just
drives me crazy you know what I mean
just so needy he hasn't confirmed
anything in chat we're jogging in chat
oh talk to me uh why aren't you talking
to me dude I'm doing a live podcast man
and I'm talking about stuff you know
what I mean
so many entitled [__]
in the world all right anyways let's get
back to this because I got to go with
the hour is almost up
so guys you know this is uh
this is a lot man like people are losing
money you know so it's like you gotta be
careful out here right now man
uh the artificial intelligence is
getting graded there they're they're
they're faking your voice they're faking
your you know and then they're calling
people and people are gullible like this
is worse than the remember the emails
you would get from the uh Nigerian
lawyer like the fact that people were
getting scammed by that imagine how much
money people have lost to a to a fake
Nigerian lawyer
how this is taking it to another level
it's not even an I it's not a Nigerian
lawyer it's your mom it's her voice or
someone's someone's voice and you know
it'd be like I'm getting called by my
wife and she's like I'm being kidnapped
and said you know and then I'm like oh
my God I just sent a hundred thousand
dollars and then she walks in the door
like hey babe you know you're like wait
I thought you were kidnapped and you're
like so be careful out here in these
streets y'all you know what I mean like
you really got to be careful now like
like
like this is crazy man you know
uh and this is and there's more stories
like this like here's another one
um this is another one uh of a of of
like another fake thing where an image
of black smoke billowing next to uh the
you know the Pentagon
it it did something to the stock market
and it was a fake image
like
guys
the internet's not not necessarily real
it's a tool we use but not everything on
there is real man not everything that
people say is real
some of this stuff is like
you know you got to be careful
you know what I mean like you really got
to be careful of what
you read and see on the internet because
this stuff
so this one's crazy it like crashed the
stock market for a second and then it
rebounded but it's just getting too it's
getting too sophisticated how the AI is
you know causing issues you know and
then like
um
I'll just leave you with this oh I oh
you know what I forgot I want to just
talk about this one too I mean also the
reason why you have to have some
Integrity in American Idol is
you know just to just to get back to it
real quick because this is so this was
like something I saw too look at this
one of the winners of American Idol is
now back on the subway singing for money
talk about a winner
American Idol
and now they are back
singing in a bus singing in the subway
so
should that a person have won was there
an agenda going on that year I don't
know because I wasn't I don't think I
watched that year
because I have I don't always watch but
I just in the last in the last two two
years I've really gotten into it I
really like it right but this is like
that's crazy okay I just want to point
that out that's crazy that that person
okay like what okay
won the show
they won the show y'all
and they back singing for money on the
subway
you know that's crazy
all right wanna and then getting back to
the AI wait where's my story I wanted
just a domain all right so we'll finish
with this so Ice Cube he's like AI is
demonic and he'll says he sues anyone
who uses or recreates his voice
wow
imagine how this because it's like there
is some fun in it too
if you think about it there's some fun
let me see ice cube I mean of course the
AI gonna be like Yay you know what I
mean
today was a good day I mean that's like
that's what you're gonna use it for so
there's gonna be some fun things in that
and now Ice Cube's like I'm gonna sue
you but I get it so what do you guys
think of AI
you know what I mean what do you think
of AI you know
is it like is it demonic like are we
gonna have to just face it the AI is
here and we we can't put it back in the
box like what are we gonna do you know
like I'm just telling everybody like
public service announcement be careful
out there don't believe like if you get
a call from someone you know and they're
in distress
confirm that it's them
okay confirm that it's them because you
know this kind of stuff is like this is
where the world is going in it's it's
like I think we're living in a time of
um like when cell phone phones first
came out I remember like cell phones
first came out and people were like you
know
you know you're you're a drug dealer if
you have a cell phone or you know what I
mean like when technology comes out
people are afraid of it and they're like
well what are we this is this is
terrible you know and so are we living
through that now I mean is AI going to
be a tool
that we're just going to be using in our
lives is it going to help us like what
like people keep talking so much about
how bad it is but
if the AI
if we put a hey solve cancer and the AI
just starts thinking and working and
working and working and he finds ways to
solve cancer is that gonna be great or
like to help your life like you know
you're walking out the house and the AI
is like oh Eric don't forget your keys
oh thank you hey Eric you have um a
meeting today at what you call it maybe
it's going to help people what I'm
thinking about my mom and her dementia
and what if there's AI house and AI
could be like you know hey remember this
uh you know you know what I'm saying
like I'm just thinking of like so many
things where maybe in the future AI is
gonna
it's a tool that can help Society I
think we have to start to look at it
like that too but of course all we think
about is The Terminator and it's going
to be like well this is going to be the
end
I mean so
but anyway guys
um I appreciate you guys
once again being here at riffing with
Griffin you know I need you to subscribe
Please Subscribe remember and I'm gonna
I'm coming to Huntsville I'm coming to
uh into June 21st that that weekend is
going to be you know Nashville on the
21st and then the weekend I'm gonna be
at Huntsville so guys come come check me
out there as you guys know I'm on Twitch
daily love me some twitch so come check
me out there uh and you know what I mean
um
and then you know you want to support
there's always uh you know patreons
there for you to support if you want to
do that too as well and I appreciate you
guys always being being a part of this I
love the comments I love the interaction
you know I love the support please try
to share if you really enjoy my podcast
uh you know even if you don't even if
you're like you want to say your friend
man this guy got crazy takes you got to
see this that do that too I like all of
that okay but y'all know what time it is
it's that rap recap
[Music]
oh with the old man raps
shout out to my boy Chris you
sending me these beats
oh sheets
you know how we do oh LeBron James
he might retire
the Lakers they need to make a new hire
oh this rap is fire
you could call me science
[Music]
to move your face
dead like Patrick Swayze
[__] these Rhymes lazy
but nothing saves me
American Idol
get some Integrity
so we can see the best person they can
be
y'all thanks for watching
ripping with Griffin live in full effect
you know how we do it
when I see you
next week
[Music]
thank you